i had gotten lost on a bus
following people at the gare du nord and i
sat at a bus stop
i was crying like in a goof as
a kid and asking someone
tell me aim to keep the thread
strangers here everything turns to the right and
you arrived I was not at home with nothing
to see it was really a moment when
already I am not yet sure of being safe from
which I find myself there lost
what so here it is  like that so
I was shown so there is I
applied for asylum
that's me that day so there it is so I have
more heart all my body is there but
my heart and is no longer there  what did
he stay at home
[Music]
my name is roger 42 years old of rwandan origin
and i am a social worker
here at on vu l i am at the listening service
we meet refugees or
registered and we direct them either to
housing searches
training searches guidance
called I left rwanda because
of a situation of g  at a given moment
I had the chance of two encounters to
meet first a person who
served us during the genocide is
a second person who had to who had to
get me out of this situation I had
to hide from you I  just remember
that i all i wanted is
soggy to find refuge
protection arrives in belgium so i
do my background exams i get my
papers i meet different genders
as i call them gentlemen
remaining quarters social assistance  cps 2
of internet so the first accommodation that
I found in austr it was thanks to
him he encouraged me to train so
I started an intensive Dutch course
and there
and encourage us so that I could
study
to put
it integration requires resilience
if we are not terminated we pick ourselves up
when I often have beneficiaries who
tell me I am giving up the
integration process is a process that lasts
for years it is wanting  recognize  struire
and therefore to the visuals
that's why it
interested me thade and collected
Afghan colleagues so this nest to
take time sometimes you'll have the accent yes
ok but you'll get by and at the
war at home I'm coming here I have no
choice
so it's not something we can
negotiate again if I had the choice I
'll be at home now when
I get here you have to see I'm here what is it  we
do either you put me in a
ladder ball and so I stay on the
system and they don't see me where I am
here and you can call on my
knowledge
you really need a period of adaptation
you give him  the protection then at
night of the weapons give the weapons to
get out of it